anyone here that doesn't know anything
about c-sharp
okay looks like I'm the only one and
anyone here who has experience with
Kafka
okay so if you are on one of those sites
okay you still have time to go to
another room okay because maybe we'll
not teach you or I will not teach you a
lot of things but if you decide to stay
what I can promise that I will try to
give you a good time here and maybe
teach you one or two things so my name
is guillerm Freire
it turns out that guillermi is a really
hard name to pronounce if you don't
speak Portuguese so feel free to call
migi okay you can even find me as ghee
on a lot of places so it's a good way to
start
one thing that I believe you should know
about me is that I have a no habit that
when I go to a different country I
always like to look for things that we
have in common things that connect my
country Portugal to that place so this
time I did the same regarding Portugal
and England and we have a lot of things
in common okay
um for I'm not sure if you know but port
wine has a huge relationship with with
England but also I could find this
interesting fact we have the oldest
Alliance in the world anyone know about
that
yeah so you you can win a prize if you
go to
to one of those trivia contests so in
1386 we got together and we created the
base of the relationship that we have
nowadays collaboration and peace and on
that treaty I was curious what was the
definition of that treaty that may just
be so successful in this relationship
for such a long time and I could found
this document this is the actual
document or artifact I'm not sure we
should name this kind of thing that is
currently stored in Portugal and here we
State a lot of things that are important
like uh typical of the ages that
Portuguese King should marry a British
princess and things like that but also I
have found this section that I'm really
concerned about it and I believe that I
need to share with you what is here
anyone here knows Latin
no but Google translate this and
according to Google Translate
this says that the evaluation of a
Portuguese individual must always be
conducted with a green card
not sure if you know what does that mean
but it means that on the way out you
need to vote with a green card otherwise
this will end okay
once again thank you all for taking the
time to be here with me today
I want to explain you what we'll be
doing here during this session
and when I start learning Kafka I was
joining a company that used Kafka as an
event driven solution okay to build
event driven architectures and I decided
that I wanted to learn and usually I
like to go to YouTube and find good
talks in NDC and other conferences about
the subject that I'm trying to learn and
what I realized is that most talks on
Kafka were not targeting me on that
scenario okay they were basically going
through a lot of features of Kafka but
they will go from the basics to things
that usually will not need at least as a
developer often you need them in the
perspective of a data engineer I'm
talking about things like Kafka connect
or Kafka streams so I was looking for
the basics okay and I wanted to see a
talk with a real example where the
person's share is pains during the
process of developing that thing
so I decided to create that talk that
talk where I couldn't find so this is a
talk for c-sharp Developers
where we will see a lot of codes we'll
see architecture diagrams we will talk
about how to address certain problems
that you'll find in event driven
applications and we will do that without
slides okay we'll see code and
architecture diagrams I hope that you
are comfortable with that Okay so
what's problem what real problem is that
one that I want to share with you
I'm not sure if anyone here knows but
I'm in fact a small content creator okay
and when I say small this is not a joke
about autoim
I'm in fact smoke I don't have a lot of
followers or subscribers or whatever
in fact in August last year I started my
YouTube channel
I finally got my 2000 subscribers so
both clap for me and but there's one
cool thing that I really like about my
YouTube channel let me show you that if
you go to
me open in my browser
if you go to YouTube and you search by
keyfrera you will see not only me doing
stupid faces like a YouTuber should do
but also I'm sharing the stage with a
Brazilian singer that has beautiful love
songs and I would like to share some of
this with you maybe you will like it
okay for example this one and let me
move a bit forward
can we have the sound a bit louder
no can we have the sound bit
you can see the type of music that this
is so
I don't know if anyone here knows
Portuguese but what he's saying is a
music about making love so this is the
type of thing that you don't get when
you search for Nick chapsters online
okay
okay so as I told you I will not be
using slides
so I will be using my browser a lot and
one thing that I wanted to share with
you is that as a content creator you
quickly understand that is not
sustainable okay you do a lot of things
you you like what you do you like to
teach but your wife will ask you where
others that will pay the bills right and
I don't have a good answer for that so I
decided to do what everyone does I start
my patreon account okay I have a patreon
account and this from this patreon
account that you'll build an event
driven architecture okay an event driven
system
by the way last slide I promise
if anyone decides to become a patron
during the talk I brought you something
special from Portugal okay and by the
end I will have a prize okay if no one
decides to do that you will ruin my demo
okay so shame on you
by the way
um let's keep let's keep moving on so
patreon whereas as I was telling you
my idea from patreon is not only that
people can support me okay it's one of
main roles of patrons but also to keep
them access to stuff that I don't know
nowadays what will be okay my first idea
was okay let me give access to source
code okay source code that will be
hosted on GitHub as it should be so I
need to have a way that I get a new
Patron and I will and that Patron will
land into a GitHub account okay into a
GitHub organization but that brings a
lot of problems for example one of them
is that I can't get an username by 4
GitHub from an email okay so I need to
have some things here in the middle
the other thing that I have found out
that is really painful is working with
patreon API is really a mess poor
documentation and don't trust the
documentation at all so you will learn a
lot of things trying trying to do that
so what I decided to do
was let me show you the first diagram
that we have to see today
was my first step was basically this
okay
I have patreon on that side I want to
look for that API and they they have one
good thing that is they they have web
books so I can subscribe to a members
created members updated things like that
and then I will have a natural function
there okay and that Azure function will
write data to Kafka okay I will explain
what does that mean okay what is
important for you to know is that since
I don't trust the patreon API okay
because I really don't trust them
because I follow the documentation until
the moment I add the first Python and I
realized that it was all a lie okay and
I need to to change a lot of things now
to cope with it so I know that
I will have that that Azure function
acting as an HTTP trigger and I want to
write to Kafka okay so the first
question where do I host Kafka that
common question
I can install it on Docker I can install
it on my machine I can install it on
whatever server I want AWS Azure
whatever what I decided to do was using
this thing let me just zoom in for your
benefit confluent quality
by the way I don't work for Confluence
most talks about Confluence about CAF
card from Confluence I don't work for
them confluent cloud is a kind of a
platform as a service right that will
give you Kafka the benefit is that since
I'm the only person working in this
organization I I don't want to be
installing Kafka and configuring a lot
of things so why not
the benefit of Confluence Kafka is that
when you create your cluster that's your
first concept of Kafka you have a
cluster for Kafka you can always decide
and I think you should be able to read
here
where do you want to install it it's
basically saying that I decide that I
want to have my cluster on Azure okay
good news this talk was not yesterday
otherwise this will be a problem okay
yesterday Azure was a huge problem
so you can decide if you want it on
Azure on AWS and other places so I
decided that I want to have it on azure
and work is inside of my confluent Kafka
cluster okay that's the next question
so as I was showing you here on the
diagram I'm writing to this thing that
I'm naming PRD patreon events so on that
thing it's basically a topic okay what
is a topic in Kafka let me show you here
something that may help you okay
a topic in Kafka you can think about it
like a queue but it's not a Queue at all
okay it's an event log okay it's a place
where we will be always appending data
so the way that you write things into
Kafka is always adding something to the
end
each entry on this event log has a
number okay we call that the offset
so this is the detail that makes Kafka
really efficient because
the most the cheapest option that you
have to write data in software is
appending okay you don't rewrite
anything
and besides that if you find out that
you have a network on this message that
is here on position five
you can change it okay it's immutable
what does that mean if you want to do
anything else you just have one option
okay just append something to the end
that will fix it like in accounting okay
like you should do
so the other thing that is really cool
about Kafka is that messages are always
in order okay what does that mean it
means that if you want to know the state
of your system you have one option you
go for position one and you read till
the end okay and you keep breathing and
you know the stage
the other thing that makes Kafka really
efficient is that
it's it's not like a queue because you
don't you decouple completely the
process of reading from the process of
deleting data okay while in the queue
you get the message and that message is
not there anymore
on Kafka you read it you do whatever you
want with it but it stays there one day
it may be deleted it may be okay it's up
to you we'll talk about that later
and now this this event log okay this
log file let's let's call them a log
file okay each line of log is is part of
our topic it's a message
how does this relate to our cluster so
let's take a look
okay this is our cluster okay and here
you find a concept that is a partition
so when you go to Kafka and you say okay
please give me a new topic it will ask
you how many partitions do you want
what is the partition
basically I lied to you the topic is not
a file okay it's a distributed file
let's say so each partition will live in
a different broker the broker is a kind
of a server a node in the cluster and
this gives you a lot of benefits why
because Kafka is highly scalable okay so
so you can realize Kafka is used in
organizations like Netflix LinkedIn
PayPal on my YouTube account all those
huge corporations as you can see and
when you define that you want multiple
partitions this will give the option of
to Kafka to host those partitions on
multiple Brokers so you have a slice of
that topic inside of a different machine
that gives you scalability in terms of
writing but also in terms of reading
what's the benefit now you may be asking
why do I have for example partition one
in Blue on that side and in Orange here
on the middle and in here again
because
Kafka needs to have a way to make sure
that it doesn't lose data okay and when
you go and you write something to Kafka
Kafka will decide okay on which
partition do I want to write this thing
that billiard is sending to me so I will
write it on partition number two okay
and now
let's say that the broker tool has one
problem and it goes away so do I lose my
data okay
possibly unless I have some
configurations to avoid that but one
thing that Kafka keeps doing is using
replicas and what does that mean is that
the data will be replicated from this
side
to the other ones okay you can think
about this
thing of the logs as like the
transaction log from SQL Server if you
have ever used it okay you have a
mystery of events that let you fulfill
those replicas
to the partitions on the top in blue we
call them levers to the partitions on
orange we call them followers
what does that mean it means that if the
broker two goes away it dies for some
reason okay let's say I'll this machine
is lost what will happen is that Kafka
will start a leather election process so
we will decide from the other ones who's
the best candidate to now be the leader
what does that mean next time that I
need to write or read data is with that
one that I will communicate so enough of
Concepts let's start to see some code
right so we map this thing
and let me scroll back into the left so
we recap where we were so remember that
I told you that we have here an Azure
function
that has an HTTP trigger and now I want
to write into this thing how can we do
that
the most common approach is installing
this package
confluent.net client okay it's pretty
fine nothing wrong about it
the problem is that if you build event
driven applications in a new
organization or in multiple applications
you will see that you keep rewriting the
same kind of stuff okay in top of of the
confluent Kafka client you will do a lot
of stuff over and over again by the way
if you don't work with c-sharp they also
have
versions for Java go and other languages
as well so what I prefer to do is use
this one
that the name is Kafka flow
and capture flow as one advantage by the
way it's built on top of confluent
clients so you keep using the one that I
just showed you but it gives you some
things on top of it that will simplify
your life okay and we'll see a lot of
them in a moment the definition is clear
it's easier to maintain it it's a
win-win in my opinion by the way always
leave a start to to open source projects
it's always helpful for open source
maintainers it's a good thing to do so
Kafka flow let's see how I'm using Kafka
flow
Visual Studio
can everyone reads this okay yeah
I'm using the light mode just for the
sake of presentation but I think it's it
reads better on this room so here I have
my HTTP trigger as you can see I'm not
doing anything to it I'm just getting
the body as a memory stream and I'm
following to a different place in my
application
and that different place we take
advantage of this thing that I will show
you so what have I done on this
application
Kafka flow is a nougat package as well
and then what I do is that I will
configure dependency injection okay and
I can do that on my programs yes startup
CS an extension method like I'm doing
here whatever you prefer so the thing is
you have access to your I service
collection and now you start defining
how is your relationship with Kafka so I
will say okay please add Kafka
I will select the login provider that I
want to use and then I will say okay
please connect to this broker with this
username and password so to those two
I'm basically providing the credentials
and the endpoints that confluent cloud
gave me okay basically that if you are
using your Docker localhost chess set
localhost and the number of the ports
then I need to to go to our next concept
on Kafka so
when we are talking about publish
subscribe anything that writes is a
publisher anything that reads is a
subscriber on Kafka we give them we give
them different names okay
something that will write data we call
them a producer something that will read
later we'll call them a consumer okay
those are the two concepts that you must
know so if they are coming in into the
topic someone is producing it if the
data is getting out of the topic getting
it doesn't go anywhere but someone is
reading from there it's a consumer
so what I'm doing here on using
classical flow is that I'm saying okay
please add this producer
with this name this name will act as a
key whatever I I want that okay whenever
I want it I use this this key to do it
then I will say every time that I use
this producer please write to this topic
if I prefer to overwrite this value when
I'm sending the message I can do it and
then I say okay since I don't have a lot
of money let's save some Network cost
and storage cost and use compression so
this is one thing that you can use with
Kafka there are several algorithms that
you can pick if you search online you
will see that there's always a trade-off
between them
from my experience gzip is the one that
performs better when you need an overall
performance of reading and writing but
if you prefer faster reads or faster
rides you can choose another algorithm
as well so and it's as simple as going
here and just select the different one
as simple as that
so I have now this producer is
completely configured so through
dependency injection I've defined where
it connects and what I need inside of
this application and what I am doing
I have also here through dependency
injection this patreon publisher is the
one that will be invoking the producer
to send the message
but before that I think it's important
to see what a message is so let me go
here to a different place and I will
open another application that is pretty
cool if you want to use Kafka
I'm not affiliate to them
and if Azure is now back I should be
able to access it
do
okay will not be able to see that and
that sucks so let's go through
Confluence Cloud it works as well so
let's go to the topics
okay and let's open your topic messages
and now one thing that happens with
Kafka is that you need to say always
where do you want to start to read okay
and this one there's no message why
friend he said yesterday
okay
yeah yesterday this was really this
really sucks because of the thing that
happened with um with Azure and I'm not
sure if it's still recovering to be
honest
yesterday at night it was pretty fine
okay doesn't matter let me explain you
that and in a moment we'll get back to
here to see okay we have a message here
so a message will be something like
let's go and open
a message will have a value okay as you
can see here the value will always be
something as like a binary data will not
be for example enforcing you to be a
Json or a given type of data you can
send jsons you can send things using
Avro Avro is one of the most common
protocols that you see when you talk
about Kafka or for example you can use
other things like protobuf whatever for
Kafka it basically doesn't care and that
is one of the biggest advantages of
Kafka why you can see huge organizations
using Kafka and if you impose a given
contract a given protocol what will
happen is that one day the data team
will need to do something to connect to
a different platform and if you enforce
them to be Json they will avoid it and
they will bring other technology into
the apps that's one of the advantages of
Kafka because you keep growing your
business adding stuff and you keep using
the same infrastructure for it and that
is awesome
the other thing that you can do is
Define another another will always be a
kind of a key value pair okay you can
Define your things like message types
they are pretty useful for this
realization you can send other things
like
keys that you use for item fantasy those
type of things but also you can Define
this one is optional a key okay
and when you define a key
one thing happens and I will explain you
with the source code so let's go to this
patreon publisher
okay and on the patreon publisher is the
one where I'm getting through dependency
injection my producer accessor that is
the one that Kafka flow is sending me
and I will say okay please get the one
with that name that I told you because I
want to publish some messages and now I
go here and I say okay please produce a
new message
and I want to produce with this key
the key is one important concept why I
can send a no value there and if I send
a no value what will happen is do you
remember those partitions across the
brokers if I send a no what Kafka will
do is using a round robin algorithm to
decide where that message should land
okay it will basically decide for
himself where it should go that's the
best approach if you value throughput of
your system okay but then with that
approach you may have a problem why
the order of consuming messages is only
guaranteed per partition what does that
mean if I'm imagine that I have two
machines reading data from a topic and I
have the risk that one of them will be
connected to one partition and the other
to the other one if I get two messages
here one on this side and the other on
this side and they start to be
processing the wrong order that may be a
problem okay imagine on my case I have a
new Patron and it tells me okay I I'm a
new Patron my payment status is pending
and then I receive another event from
the patreon API that says okay this
person is now active Okay it already has
space this is completely different if
you swap around okay I should do
different things if I receive the
pending after the paid right so for me
it's really important to have order and
I can achieve that through the message
key
when Kafka C is the same message key
over and over again it will always send
it to the same partition that way I can
ensure that my consumer will always get
the messages regarding that Patron in
order okay so this is one important
concept to keep in mind when building
these type of applications
then what I'm doing on this case is okay
so let's send a message into that
and besides that let's set some matters
okay I'm setting here another for the
sake of knowing on the other side on the
consumers when patreon has published
this this event okay we call it the
trigger okay it was a member created a
member of plated whatever
as you can see I'm doing this thing that
is sending bytes instead of a string why
as I told you Kafka doesn't care about
data types okay it works with binary
data sometimes you will see through
Kafka flow that you will be sending the
data type but in fact I configured a
serialization protocol to convert those
things and we'll see that in a different
application
okay moving on
so next up next application let's go
here to our slides now I have a new
Patron that Patron was collected through
this Azure function now I have a new
event on the python events if we go down
what was my next step
Next Step was this part here that you
can see from ear to ear
so now that I have those events I'm not
doing anything to them I'm not treating
them now I want to treat them now I need
to know what in fact is that thing
because if you look into one of those
events what you will understand is that
what what patreon is telling me okay I
have this person that is your Patron and
I updated it and now I need to look into
the payload and find what happens okay I
don't have semantics on top of it so I
need to understand if it was now if now
it's a patient that is active you see
it's someone that cancels the
subscription whatever so what I will be
doing is that I will every spectrum
manager that will be managing a catalog
of the information and then I will be
publishing domain events that are useful
for myself
one thing that I learned with this
approach of having this thing here
as you can see is that every single time
that that thing on the top the patron
does crazy things I can't absorb them
and then I handle it for example
I have the risk that they changed the
contract from one day to the other one
because the contract that is not on the
documentation is not true
so I don't trust them so this way I'm
sure that I will collect everything and
I will handle it later okay it's one
good thing when you don't trust third
parties
now I can convert that thing and one
thing that you can see on this
application is that here I'm not only
producing data into this application
right I'm also consuming what does that
mean it means that one application on
Kafka can be a producer and a consumer
can be multiple consumers and multiple
producers whatever you may have a lot of
applications doing a lot of things with
Kafka so Kafka is not only for
microservices okay by the way by the end
you will understand that this is not a
talk on how to avoid over engineering
okay I know that I have a lot of
services here that maybe I didn't need
it but for the sake of the demo I think
it's pretty useful so let's go take a
look into this patreon manager and see
how I have it configured so new
application
and once again you will see that most of
the configuration is kind of the same so
I have here
extension method to configure dependency
interaction
and I'm using Kafka flow once again
but now I have one different thing that
is one of the advantages of Kafka flow
when you use the confluent client often
and you have one application that in the
background is consuming things
often you need to implement a background
service yourself
this way just with this simple method
call you have it on Kafka flow so it's
one small Advantage then I'm saying more
of the same okay what is my cluster auto
connect it and now we see a different
thing oh yeah the consumer
on this consumer I will need to say
connect to this topic
I will give it those names that will
talk about it later
now I'm saying here a different thing
that is one cool feature of cafo that is
imagine having one application
running.net that is consuming events
after event after event in a single Loop
okay you will look into that machine and
you will see okay this machine is
nothing anything okay it's handling only
one message at the time often you can
scale out that thing
inside of that application itself so
what Kafka flow gives you on with this
option is a multi-thread consumer okay
inside of the same application and even
then it will preserve the order okay you
it doesn't require you to scale out your
server as a whole okay your application
as a whole you can only scale out
through threads it's one small Advantage
as well
so and then I'm saying please whenever
you start for the first time reading
this topic please start from the
beginning otherwise what Kafka will do
is just get your message from the end of
the queue okay so so you only see the
new ones but on Kafka one cool thing is
that you can always recover everything
from the beginning how is that useful
for example I have developed that first
part that I showed you first so I
collect some events then when I deploy
this patreon manager into production it
went there he looked into everything
that was there and revealed my story
based on the historic equator one day
when I decide to for example have a
mailing list for my patrons I can do the
same I just build one application that
looks into events and with from the
beginning and builds everything again
okay it's one of the other advantages
why many companies like Kafka okay
so as I was telling you I now I've
registered all those things and now here
you can find one concept that if you
ever used something like mediator this
maybe will make a lot of sense to you
it's a common practice on this type of
event inventory even or applications
with commands
so Kafka flow gives you a middleware
pipeline
it will let you register a set of things
that will be executed in sequence when
it receives a message
for example in this case what I'm
telling him is
okay please whenever you see a new
message coming from that topic use this
realizer okay I'm saying okay please use
Newton soft.json
to just realize that message okay I can
use another ones like as I told the
message pack that there are a news offer
inside of Kafka flow that you can use
once you get that type I want you to use
the type of message to understand who
should handle it okay and you will
recognize that from
mediator as well so I'm adding endlers
into my application and on that case if
it sees like a patreon a plated event it
knows that the patron applied to the
event handler should handle it okay so
that way I segregate the logic and it's
quite useful then I can say okay please
if you don't see anything else just
write a message for me or I can send an
alert I can park that message somewhere
it's completely up to you so now that I
have this thing let me show you what
this is doing
that thing we'll call a process that
will try to understand how to apply the
catalog with that and then we'll decide
to publish those events that I showed
you here okay so we'll write this thing
here and this thing here
this one that you see on the left are
domain events for me okay new thing
activated deactivated things like that
the one on the right is a snapshot of
that user and this will be useful by the
end when we get back to it but for now
let's focus only on this one but I what
I wanted to show you is that when I
collect that data I'm also finding the
events that I want to publish and into
multiple topics and I can use one cool
thing on Kafka that is batch processing
okay as you can see right here what does
that mean you can send one message one
call with multiple things and those
things don't need to Target exactly the
same topic you can see that I'm
providing two different variables for
different messages
and this way you can always decide
between a trade-off on how the
throughput of your application or the
for example
the bandwidth that you want to consume
the latency of your solution as well
right
so it's another advantage of Kafka and
now I have done that is that on on my
configuration through Kafka flow I went
here and I have as you can see multiple
consumers were also a producer
this time I'm using the same compression
algorithm but I'm now using a middleware
to realize with the system.text.json on
this case
and I'm also defining this x what is
this thing
remember those those diagrams that I
showed you with the Brokers and the
partitions and maybe one of the Brokers
goes away
how can I protect myself if I can't lose
data I can set this parameter the ax or
acknowledgments to either none what does
that mean I send the data into Kafka and
I don't care about it okay maximum
throughput of the system basically that
I can say please let me know if the
leader committed this thing successfully
okay so if it's on the leader I'm okay
and I keep moving on
or I can say if I can't lose anything at
all I can say please just tell me that
everything is fine whenever all the
replicas and the leader trust that they
already committed that into into that
okay so this is one of the things one of
the reasons
why I see Kafka as a kind of a libraries
between a queue a message system and a
database because you have a lot of
tweaks that you can do to have data to
be really consistent on Kafka so not
saying that into the database okay don't
get me wrong but it's kind of in some
aspects
so we have our producer and now
let's go here a bit to the end and as
you can see now I'm using only the is
activated events so
I have a new pattern the patron went to
that first queue now I process that and
now I have semantics now I know that I
have one event that is new pattern is
activated okay now I know that I can
give him access to GitHub but I can't do
it because from an email I can't get
okay give him access so what I will be
doing is sending him an email on this
case through sendgrid to with a link
that will guide him to a web page where
he fills in the the username username
and I will relate those two things and
publish to GitHub
but this brings me a problem that is
Kafka as a concept of at least one's
message delivery
if I don't do anything what may happen
is that you start receiving a lot of
emails from me saying okay please
activate that happened okay this is a
real story and what can you do to to do
that it's a it's a simple thing that in
fact you should do in most inventory one
applications we find one okay this one
that is using um a logic on your system
that will give you the item quantity so
what I'm doing I have this class
that is using an Azure table okay where
I use the patron ID and patreon email to
duplicate messages okay you should
always do that especially on top of of
Kafka okay because Kafka has this logic
that it will make sure that you get that
message at least once but at least once
so keep that in mind make your messages
as important it was one huge problem
that I had on the first run on this
thing so moving on
now
as you can see I've sent that email this
row Arrow here represents the click on
the email now this the person goes to
this webpage and this web page now I
have the username and email so why not
adding it to GitHub
if I had it right there into itself I
can have a huge problem that is GitHub
as in the API as throttling so I have
just a set of requests that I can do per
hour okay first time that I've done it I
have misconfigured my access key so what
can happen is that you have a networking
configuration or it may expire something
like that and I can read through those
that that pattern on that moment because
imagine that you go there okay you want
to get access to the source code you
fill in your username you try you get an
echo it's right back you get the network
okay and you say okay I will get back to
it later and you never go back and now I
lose your precious three dollars that
can help me so I don't want that so what
you do on an event driven system like
this one is that you decouple the
producing of messages from the consuming
of those messages
so what I'm doing is as long when I have
that username I will publish a message
into a topic a different topic just
saying for this pattern now I have this
username and now you can see what I do
now on this side you can see that from
that one I'm reacting to that message to
update GitHub here on the top
but also look that you I not only have
that Arrow to here so this consumer but
also this one
this is the type of thing that you can
do with a typical queue right so you
can't read the same message for two
purposes
so what is happening here
Kafka
as this concept let me show you
if you go here to those two applications
you will see and maybe you remember that
I told you that I will talk about that
later
that in one of them I have this group ID
this to this we call the consumer group
so on one I have this group ID
on the other one on the patreon manager
if we go here
I have a difference group ID
by giving them two different group ideas
now they both can read two different
messages the same message in for two
different purposes
I like to compare that to kind of
reading a book with a bookmark Okay this
may be useful for you to get the concept
imagine the following scenario okay this
book is designing products that people
love okay and now let's say
that this bookmark represents my
daughter okay she's six so she's really
into designing products that people love
uh she doesn't know how to read yet but
okay
let's say that this represents her so
now I know on which place she is
currently position it
this one with Darth Vader and a
stormtrooper it's mine so I'm the dark
force in my home as you can see this one
represents where I am what does this
mean the same book may be read by two
different persons right but in fact
there's one other thing since my
daughter doesn't know how to read
this bookmark will be used not by her
but for her purpose okay for her I will
read the book through different
consumers and those consumers maybe me
that today I read and I will bookmark it
tomorrow my wife came into here and she
reads two more pages and she will
bookmark when I get back to this thing I
know where she left off okay I don't
need to read those two pages again and
this is how Kafka can really scale on
this type of applications so basically
what Kafka will be doing
is keeping track of the offset do you
remember the position on the topic is
the offset you will keep track of that
offset as a bookmark but we'll keep
track of that offset for this first
application but also to the other one
because they are from two different
consumer groups this way if I decide to
for example let's say that
GitHub through through due to the
throughput and rate limiting that that
we have I can scale up this thing at all
okay otherwise I will have problems so I
may have only one consumer for this one
but I can have two different consumers
for this one and they will not compete
with each other okay one will get one
message other will get another one and I
keep scaling that way it's beneficial on
that way besides that
the The Bookmark is inside the book okay
it's not with me okay I don't have a
piece of paper with me saying on which
page did I left the book last time the
same way with Kafka what Kafka does is
that it will store the offset for each
consumer group either on zookeeper that
is another technology on Apache but or
most recently now we are able to start
that inside of a topic in Kafka okay you
don't need to do anything about that but
you will be doing that okay so that's
another benefit let me see if I already
can access this thing so I could show
you that
if we can't you need to trust myself
okay so maybe here we can see on the
overview
consumption
and on consumer lag
okay perfect
okay
okay look at this what does this mean is
that this topic that I'm showing you
that is a topic for development
as this client ID that in fact is a
consumer or a consumer group
that last position is the offset number
nine
what now Kafka knows is that if you are
in in page 100 and we have 200 pages on
the book you have a leg of another
another 100 pages to read
it's the same concept on on the on the
topic right if you know that you have 20
messages and you are currently in the
nine it will tell you here that you have
one 11 to read so you can calculate flag
and this is really useful for in in
systems that are used like the ones that
Netflix and Linkedin should have for for
sure
when you have a problem you see that
messages are not going through and you
need to react to that so you go to those
dashboards and you can see what you you
need to do you just scale out for for a
few minutes and then everything gets
back and it's a good tool to have
okay so what we have more by the way
I used to work on a company where we had
a process that will run every single
Wednesday I think so and on when and for
that process it was really heavy
calculation it took a long time and the
problem is that at a given moment we
were
almost always missing an SLA that react
with our clients so on Wednesday the
personal support will go to to some
monitoring and we'll look into something
like this to see okay do I need to scale
anything to make sure that you will not
miss the SLA okay and when you have
something like this it's really useful
to guide you on those decisions
okay so let's go back into our diagram
and now we know what is the topic what
is a producer how what is a consumer how
to read and write data using c-sharp I
show you using Kafka flow if you want to
use the confluent client it's kind of
the same the difference is that you'll
be writing a lot of code yourself for
small things like if you want to have
multiple threads consuming things like
restful shutdowns this realization
sometimes gives a lot of work but it's
easy it's up to you we talk about some
of the most common concerns that you may
have when you you talk about Kafka okay
so you may have now a clear picture of
what does that mean
we have seen an architecture that
follows basically the idea of an
evolutionary architecture what does that
mean it means that
one day my business me as a small
content creator this thing May grow and
I will start having access to different
things so if one day I need to have ear
on the side a different system that I
want to give access for me will be as
simple as adding another box here that
will do kind of the same as this one
okay and consume the same events to
there with the side benefit that now I
can consume everything from the
beginning
okay it's one extra benefit
the last thing that I wanted to share
with you is regarding this one that I on
purpose left for the end
okay do you remember that I told you
that Kafka can behave as a kind of an
hybrid between the messaging system and
the database
why
when you write it into Kafka or when you
read it into Kafka you'll don't do
anything to the lifetime of that Trader
okay
the lifetime of data is configured
through a retention policy
so when you create a new topic let's go
here into confluent topics
and now we are an earth topic button
it will ask me which name do I want to
give to that topic
you will ask me how many partitions do I
want do I want do you remember that
and then
I need I can change the cleanup policy
of data what does that mean
I can't Define for example in this
scenario that after one week that data
should go away so those messages should
go away after one week
if I want to have really good
performance and keep that performance
system for a long time I should have a
kind of this thing okay doesn't mean
that needs to be one week but it's up to
you you can Define with your
requirements that you have for example
imagine that you have a use case where
that data due to things like gdpr and
something like that you need to throw it
away after one year after two years
something like that this will do it for
you so you know that after that time
that event will go away
but also you optimize your topic that
way you can do it through size
but the most curious option is this one
okay the Compact and this one looks kind
of strange when we we think about it
because it looks like it's not Kafka why
the way that the compact will work is
that it will look into the topic and
every single time that it finds out that
it's the moment to get the compact
working okay it needs to optimize that
topic it will look for events with the
same message key okay do you remember
the message key is the one that we make
sure that multiple messages are
relatable so they go to the same
partition
so now it will look into those messages
and will only keep the one with the
highest offset
when is this thing useful imagine that
you have a system where you want to
publish a snapshot of the current
address of your customers okay so every
time that you have a new customer you
publish a message with that
in fact you only address that matters is
exactly the last one that you have right
for the purpose of other applications so
what you do this way is that when Kafka
decides to clean up later instead of
deleting all the records will only
delete the old versions of that address
okay make sense
so you can use that for example in my
case what I'm doing is that since I'm
publishing a snapshot that says the name
the email the GitHub username
and I think it's only that
I will not keep the all the versions of
that but when the compact works it will
clean up the old versions of that thing
that doesn't mean that I only have one
version of that Patron inside of that
topic because the topic at the moment
may not be compacted at all okay it's
something that may happen
so okay we have seen that and now the
last thing as I told you
I wanted to find if I can give a price
but maybe none of you decide to become a
patron so this will go wrong for sure
but we'll find a way that I don't get
back that thing to Portugal again so
what do I have here I want to show you
another option by this demo
I'm doing kind of the same thing it's a
console application a simple.net console
application and I'm installed Kafka flow
once again and now what I've done is
more of the same
please add the cluster with this broker
how I will authenticate it
and I'm saying okay please use a new
consumer okay you can see it right here
and this consumer will be looking to a
topic that if you see on the name is my
production
patrons.fatter.snapshot so I may have
duplicates instead of the thing
and besides that I'm using a different
group ID why because I want to treat
this application as a different purpose
of consuming that data
and besides that I only have one worker
because I will run this only at once I
don't need to have to scale this thing
I'm saying okay please read everything
from the beginning
I will add a middleware to this realized
data so I get the events type
and then I'm saying please use a batch
processing that will get 100
and we'll wait just two seconds to see
if something else comes into the to the
topic and then go go to to do whatever I
want to do for example if you have a
process that is always running looping
for data to collecting batch you can
Define here for example five seconds it
will wait for five seconds seeing okay
there's anything more there's anything
more okay I reached my limit let's go
okay you can do those kind of things and
then I'm saying okay please forward that
watch into this middleware
the last thing that is really important
is this one
I'm telling him specifically please do
not store offsets what does that mean
every time that you read a message and
you process it you need to to set the
bookmark inside of the topic right to
know next time that you need to read
that topic you need to know where you
left off
Kafka flow will do that for you
so you don't need to think about that
you can always say Okay I want to do
that manually and we will decide
whenever you want to commit it or not or
you can use this simple option that says
okay please never do that when does that
is useful on synthetics like this one
where I can run this demo multiple times
and I can load all the data find a
winner and then I don't commit anything
so in an hour when I decide to run this
again I will get every single thing once
again so it's one of the advantages and
then I don't do anything else here so
just this configuration
the application will start I will
receive my batch and the batch will be
forward to this middleware where I'm
accessing to the watch as you can see
and besides that I'm applying here this
thing to the watch because I may have
duplicated data there since the compact
may not have worked at the time then I'm
filtering out any pattern from the past
to find only ones from today and then I
will print the results so let's see if
this runs
and let's see if you decide to destroy
my demo I will not be surprised with
that
or this may not run because of all the
problems that we had with Azure in the
in the last few days
okay so it's starting the first thing
that we will try to do is to connect to
to the topic okay this usually doesn't
take such a long time
but this is a demo and when you go to a
presentation and you say yeah and I will
not use slides uh this is what may
happen
so let's let's hope that this this time
it will run
okay okay here we go so what it's saying
now is okay I've connected to the topic
okay and unfortunately I have no one new
there so what will happen now is that
since I don't want to bring a gift back
to Portugal If anyone approaches me by
the end the first one with the question
will get something cool from portugalo
okay thank you all for taking the time
to be here with me today I really hope
that you'll learn something new uh on
this session and I hope that you enjoy
the rest of the conference please don't
forget to leave your votes on the way
out and remember that we have the
longest Alliance in the world okay
goodbye
foreign